- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna think about
how ions will arrange themselves
when they form solid crystals.
When they form these lattice structures.
So just in very broad brush terms,
let's say that we have a
bunch of this white cation,
and we have a bunch of this
green, or this blue-green anion.
So let's say they're
in a one-to-one ratio.
How will that look?
How will the solid look,
if you were to take
a two-dimensional slice of it?
To imagine that, we can draw
what we could call particulate models.
We're just imagining a
two-dimensional slice of the solid,
and we're just drawing
these ions as particles.
Would it look something like this,
where maybe the positive
ion is all on one side,
and then the negative
ion is on the other side,
is on the bottom if we
were to take a slice?
Would something like this make sense?
Or maybe it's random.
Maybe you have a positive there,
and then you have some
negatives right over there.
And then, maybe you have
a positive and a positive,
and then a positive right over there.
And then maybe you have some
negatives right over there.
Would this be a reasonable configuration,
as they form these ionic bonds?
Well, when we think about Coulomb forces,
we know that like charges repel each other
and unlike charges, or opposite
charges, attract each other.
And so, when these ionic solids form,
they're unlikely to form in this way,
or even in this way,
because they're gonna form
in a way that maximizes
the attractive forces
and minimizes the repulsive,
the repelling forces.
And so what would be an
arrangement that does that?
Pause this video and think about it.
Well, all the positive charges
are gonna try to get as close as possible
to the negative charges
and as far as possible
from other positive charges.
And the same thing is going to
be true of negative charges.
They're gonna try to get as far away
from other negative charges as possible,
and as close to other
positive charges as possible.
So the arrangement that
you are likely to see
is going to look something more
like a checkerboard pattern.
So it may be a positive there,
a positive there, a positive there,
a positive there, and a positive there.
These are all the same ion,
I'm not drawing it perfectly,
they'd be the same size.
And when you do these
two-dimensional representations,
these particulate models,
it is important to get the size right,
'cause we're gonna think
about that in a second.
And then the negative
charges would be in between.
So notice.
In this configuration,
every negative is surrounded by positives,
and every positive is
surrounded by negatives.
So it's maximizing the attractive forces
and it's minimizing the repulsive forces.
And if you were to think
about it in three dimensions,
you would have a lattice structure
that looks something like that.
And we have seen this in other videos.
Now another interesting
thing to think about
is the size of the ions
that form that ionic solid.
Let's say we wanted to
deal with rubidium bromide.
Rubidium bromide.
What would this look
like if I were to draw it
in a two-dimensional
particulate model like this,
and I wanted to make the
size roughly comparable
to what we would see between
the rubidium and the bromide?
Pause this video and think about that,
and I'll give you a little bit of a hint.
It might be useful to look at
this periodic table of elements.
All right, if we were to
separate this out into its ions,
it is a rubidium cation,
and a bromide anion.
Now a rubidium cation,
it has lost an electron.
So even though it still has 37 protons,
its electron configuration now
looks like that of krypton.
Now, the bromide anion, even
though it only has 35 protons,
it's going to gain an electron
to become a bromide anion,
and it also has an electron
configuration of krypton.
So both of these have the
same number of electrons,
but rubidium has two more
protons than bromide does.
And so the rubidium is going to attract
that outer shell of electrons,
that fourth shell of electrons,
more than the bromide nucleus is going to.
And so, the rubidium in this example
is going to be smaller than the bromide.
And so if I were to draw
one of these diagrams,
it would look something like this.
Let me draw the bromide first.
So I have a bromide anion, I
have another bromide anion,
another bromide anion,
maybe I have a bromide anion
right over here, bromide anion over there,
maybe a few more.
Make 'em a little bit, if I
was doing this with a computer,
I would make them all the same size.
So these are our bromide anions.
And then your rubidium cations
would be a bit smaller.
And so, our particulate
model right over here
might look something like this.
We wanna make it clear that the cation
is a bit smaller than the anion.
It would arrange, it would likely arrange
in a pattern that looks like this.
And notice, I am trying to make the sizes
roughly accurate, to show that the cation
is indeed smaller than the anion.
Although it wouldn't be
dramatically smaller.
Remember, they have the
same number of electrons.
And they don't have that dramatically
different number of protons.
And this is just a very rough drawing.
If they were dramatically different,
you might show that in
the sizes on this diagram.